I don't want to remember what I was like
before Guin saved my life when Stefani
and Blake Shelton are more in love than
ever but we won't see the couple walking
down the aisle anytime soon
we're just trying to save forever every
moment together the pair who met on the
voice in 2015 are not able to Wed in the
Roman Catholic Church until Gwen's
previous marriage is an old a process
that could take more than a year to
complete our source tells ET quote
religion is very important to Gwen and
Blake has been so respectful of that it
will take time but they will follow the
steps and make it happen we just go kind
of week by week day by day but religion
is not the only reason why Gwen and
Blake are waiting our source says quote
they made a deal to take it slow after
their divorces neither Gwen North Lake
wanted to rush into marriage they have
been living the life they've always
dreamt up together and haven't felt the
need when married Bush frontman Gavin
Rossdale in 2002 and their divorce was
finalized in 2016 meanwhile Blake has
been married twice
his latest was with country singer
Miranda Lambert which ended in July 2015
it's interesting because he really don't
realize what love can do and how
dangerous it can be and how it can
really break you and and also save or
save you at the same time this source
confirms that Gwen and Blake are
definitely committed to one another
especially when it comes to the country
singers relationship with their three
sons saying quote Gwen and Blake even
paired together while Gavin as their
father is of course a big part of the
boy's life
Blake has also become a father figure to
them it is family day today for you guys
you win and the kids and everybody out
today so they're so excited I think my
cool my cool points are going up a
little bit with the kid our source adds
one in Blake fell in love so soon after
their marriages ended that they needed
to take time to live their new lives
together they both were in very
difficult situations and relied on one
another throughout their process it
actually brought them closer together
Blake loves Gwen and had always wanted
children
so her boys have been one of the biggest
gifts in his life he raves about them
all the time
it's incredible to have
a best friend like that guy he's an
amazing person
[Music]